alors dis moi tu as un foot voyage
toinon un fou hein j'adore ça te coûte
un maximum d'argent ses voyages
oui c'est bon cela fait mal et où
n'importe où il ya des gens je suis
curieux de ce qu'il y à sur la terre
c'est trop bête quand même de quitter ce
cette boule ronde sans avoir eu la
politesse en faire le tour
c'est vrai que des fois quand fait pas
le temps de partir en voyage tu es tu
vas déjeuner à l'aéroport c'est vrai
cela ça quand j'étais jeune ouais et tu
as dit que le meilleur moment en fait la
moitié du plaisir c'était le taxi entre
paris et surtout le meilleur moment du
voyage c'est quand on prend un taxi et
qu'on va vers l'aéroport parce que ça
n'est pas encore commencé mais une fois
dans l'avion c'est déjà du passé simple
sauf si tu tombes sur un taxi comme suit
que tu vas voir le bas fichot